Frank obviously you're so associated
with sci-fi for obvious reasons no need
to mention the X file but you turned to
the spy genre for hunted what was it
that appealed to you in particular about
the spider on room well I mean there's a
lot of the x-files that has in common
with the spy genre because they both
involve paranoia and suspense and those
are things that I love that movies do so
well and I thought hunted is
particularly paranoid and suspenseful
because Sam works for a private spy
agency so she doesn't even know who her
employers are and whether she's one of
the good guys are the bad guys I just
thought that's something I hadn't seen
before and was did he know very much
about that world before you actually
came up with the idea and what sort of
research did he do into it I didn't know
anything about the world and I was
shocked to see how big it is and there
are thousands of these private spy
agencies now around the globe and
they're big business they're doing
really well and they don't talk much
about who their clients are or what the
nature of their work is but they're out
there and none of us realized which I
thought was really unsettling with it
difficult or was it easier than you
thought it would be to actually get to
information about these things to get
people to talk to you it's amazing how
people will talk you know they're
actually really happy to talk about what
they do they won't use names or
specifics but they were really open and
they brought me to their offices I met a
lot of the operatives and they're really
impressive people I mean these people
speak five languages sometimes I bet one
guy spoke 12 languages and they're great
jobs it's really interesting work so i
can see whether you're on to it is it a
bit frustrating now that you've moved
from the science fiction genre into the
spy genre that you can't have mysterious
things like vampires and aliens whenever
you fancy well I tend I tend to push it
as far as I can in the show we have a
man who stabs people in the eye with a
needle which is pretty nasty I just love
stuff like that I'm like still 14 years
old inside but you know the thing that I
always look for and I think the reason
why so many people are here at this at
this convention is you know a fictitious
world that's about something that has
ideas that you can think about so you
just watch a show and walk away it
captures your imagination and it gives
you something to ponder afterwards and I
think hunted has that
because it makes you think about good
and bad and how to do the right thing in
this world where you know we all feel so
small in relation to these huge
corporations whose agendas are opaque
you know they don't advertise what
they're doing and why and their their
their motive is profit it's not
necessarily you know anything good so I
thought those are really interesting
ideas to explore in a show was it
deliberate decisions have a female lead
and hunted it was a deliberate decision
to have a female in the lead I just
think you know a woman in this world is
so much more interesting she's
automatically an underdog it is still a
man's world and gives you all kinds of
layers just from the beginning there's
kind of a lot of similarities in a way I
think between Dana Scully aren't there
and Sam hunter was that something that
was unconscious and was that something
that was one was in your mind when
you're making it yeah i think it was
unconscious I mean I think they're both
really smart capable independent women I
think Sam hunter is far more damaged
than Dana Scully ever was much more
emotionally isolated and harder to get
to and that was the challenge honestly
in the characters that she will not
reveal herself emotionally she has no
best friend and so you had to really
make the audience want to know more
about her because she wouldn't open up
that easily and the central relationship
in her life is with her ex-lover Aiden
Marsh played by adam rayner and even
though she's broken up with him and even
though she doesn't trust him he can see
who she is he has all these insights
into her which he doesn't like because
she wants to to put up this wall and
feel invulnerable and that's why the
relationship continues and why it's
interesting to watch that and by the end
of these eight episodes you'll see a
real progression in that relationship
how difficult was it to find an actress
who could play both sides of that in a
way so and so tough and yet so
vulnerable because I know you did to
have in mind originally didn't you
Gillian Anderson yes yeah no I developed
the show with Gillian for a really long
time and she had a lot of really great
insights into the character and then
when I finally got the green light she
couldn't do it so it was incredibly
difficult to find somebody else who had
that skill set they're just
aren't that many actresses in the world
who look like that who have the
physicality and who have the acting
skill and I saw a lot of great actresses
for this part don't get me wrong but
what Melissa brought to uniquely I
thought was the ability to play this
coldness this sort of remove but also
give you the sense that there's somebody
behind that wall that you want to know
more about and there's this duality and
almost every one of her scenes that she
just does effortlessly which to me is
the secret to the to the part and don't
mentioning gum Gillian Anderson there I
know that we see there's loads of fans
out there for for the x files as well as
for hunted now of course too and there's
loads of them who would love to see
another X Files film what are your
feelings on that no I'm a big believer
in another x-files movie and I've been
sort of campaigning for it you know
publicly and behind the scenes ever
since the last movie i think the last
movie just wasn't the movie that the
cinema going public wanted it was a
little movie sort of a story of the week
kind of movie and i think what people
want is the big alien invasion movie
that was promised and is really sort of
the last chapter of The X Files
mythology so it just seems a shame to me
if it doesn't happen and i think there's
pretty strong creative and commercial
arguments for it what would you like to
see happen in that final film well i
can't say i've spoken to it you know for
years now I've been talking to Chris
Carter about it and we have a lot of
pretty clear ideas about what that story
is but I wouldn't want to spoil a
surprise and what it David and David
Duchovny and Gillian Anderson's thoughts
about it do you know our that everybody
wants to do it it's really it's been a
bit frustrating to be honest it's just
it's the studio having the faith to go
forward with the movie and I think
they're feeling because of the last film
not so confident about a final x-files
film but I have to believe in time the
the creative and commercial arguments
will prevail and how about hunted as
well Queen look forward to more series
of this if you've got the map doubt in
your mind already well I hope so I'll
find out in the next few weeks whether
it'll be another season it's been doing
very well on the BBC and on Cinemax in
the US and it certainly could go for
quite a long time so
fingers across the ideas where you might
take it off to this oh I have so many
ideas but you know the the central
question about who's trying to kill sam
and why we go a long way toward
answering that in these first eight
episodes but we don't actually get to
the end of that story so I I hope in the
season two we will miss under to ask
about strike back and also the Star
Chamber because again more spies and
crime thrillers yes well strike back was
sort of a happy accident I i moved to
london and as soon as I got here there
was a delay starting hunted so I I found
myself with nothing to do and and strike
back came my way and I was like
delighted to do it it was not like
anything I've ever done before it was
just fun it was like my inner teenager
again just you know male fantasy action
type stuff and just you know and and was
really brilliantly executed to I think
the producers and the directors of those
episodes it sit there like movies and
it's been very successful so I'm really
you know happy I got to be part of that
in the beginning Star Chamber is is a
remake I'm hoping to do of a great film
starring Michael Douglas about judges
who take the law into their own hands
they start administering the law of the
way they think it should be handed down
and I have a terrific script this being
the movie business you never know when
it will happen he would you like to see
ideally in cost well I can't talk much
about it but I will tell you that the
the central character is is a woman in
the remake when you come to events like
this comic con do you get to release
your inner geek yeah well it's funny I
was thinking about this and you know
there weren't events like this when I
was a teenager if there had been I would
have gone and I I do understand it
though I understand this kind of
devotion because for me growing up
television and movies were incredibly
important I mean it really gave me a way
of connecting to the world that I
wouldn't have had otherwise it was my
lifeline and so I think it's it's
incredible now that there are these
communities that can come together and
share this experience
and and it's a great opportunity for
people to meet other people that they
have a lot in common with
you